hello good evening and welcome to
sidetrack your sci-fi tv and movie
channel is there going to be
redundancies and even more broken
promises at mgm thanks to amazon and is
there a big project shifting to amazon
instead of mgm studios
that could be a big sign for what may be
about to happen to stargate
[Music]
hi guys
you may tell from my turn i'm a little
down to have to tell you this news that
i'm going to talk to you about today and
i've gone live i've shot straight home
from work um got my sidetracked t-shirt
on that you can buy at sidetrack.com
there's a link in the description um to
tell you this as quickly as i could
and this is a story that is happening
right now i'm literally getting messages
every couple of minutes
so um before i tell you about that
though guys please if you are new to the
channel like subscribe the bell
notification all that um
also please consider joining the channel
hit the join button um every financial
contribution that you guys make helps me
to
do more work and to spend less time at
my day job so that i can
get this news to you as quickly as
possible there's a like button and a
thanks button sorry i should say on the
on all the videos you can click that and
contribute and obviously any super chats
to come across um i can
um you know all those pennies help me to
make more content for you guys please
help me out best you can so that i can
do this more
um
basically if you are a regular site
tracker you'll know that i have a few
sources that work in and around mgm this
all started back when i first started
sidetracking nine months ago or i did a
video that actually turned out to be
wrong
um but it did get like nearly a hundred
thousand views
somebody from mgm or actually a company
that works closely with mgm email me
saying this story's wrong told me why i
started conversation with them
through that person i've now built up a
bit of a network of 12 people that
either work for mgm or work for
companies with mgm
this person originally introduced me to
them and has really helped me to get
stories to you and to understand what is
going on not just with mgm but with a
wider film industry and it's been
absolutely valuable
about an hour ago i got my first message
from one of those sources
basically saying
that amazon today or through mgm have
announced that anybody on short-term
contracts with mgm will not be having
their contracts renewed
a couple of people since then have
emailed me at least one person i've
actually talked to regularly saying that
their contract has not been renewed and
they've been put in immediate i think
they call it garden leave this is not
something i've ever come across myself i
don't work in the
public sector something i've always
public sector so this doesn't exist for
my industry
um
but basically saying that um their
contract isn't being renewed they've got
three months left on this contract
um but they're to leave now
and the last message i had off them just
a second i haven't had anything else off
there but the last message i had of them
was basically they had a security guard
stood on their shoulder and they were
clearing their desk sounds very
aggressive to me but apparently this is
quite common they deal with sensitive
information and they're not to remove
any of it
so they're going to be paid for the last
three months but they are leaving now
um i've had other messages off they
saying that this is something that's
happening
um a couple of companies that again work
closely with mgm and one person has said
when i asked them what was happening
there if they'd heard anything that was
going on he's basically said
there's nothing obviously there because
they don't work directly before they
have a contract with mgm
but the rumor going around the offices
is that that contract will not be
renewed um when it comes up for tender
but they've got a couple of years left
on that and they do legal and
contractual work for mgm
so this has come as
not necessarily a shock but it's making
me sound these people that i speak to
have basically become close to you know
i've been friendly with them i speak to
them two or three times a week to know
that they're having to go through this
does make me a little sad you know it
breaks my heart a little bit
the one person i've spoken to has
already said they knew this would come
in they've already had an offer from
another um big
studio and they're a creative i won't
say too much about them but they work in
the creative side of things and
apparently a lot of the people work on
the creative side of things doing um cgi
work or you know
get on the computers and doing that
business they're all on reasonably
short-term contracts because depend on
mgm are doing what projects are going
depends on how what skills they need and
that varies
so they don't put these people on
permanent contracts they tend to you
know the numbers go up and down
depending on what they're up to
so
he's been thinking about this for a
while he knew his contract probably
wouldn't be renewed so he's already had
an offer from another studio for me
that's great news because now i've got
an inside that studio so
from a very completely selfish point of
view i go yay but from his point of view
this postside's gonna have to change
jobs and that just sucks
um let me just quickly look at the
messages before we crack on hi shelly
paul i'm doing fine until i started
getting i just had another message
another person saying they think their
contract isn't being renewed now they're
saying that they are on a permanent
contract but redundancies have been
already being discussed that they're
already talking about possible
redundancies but we'll talk about what
all this means in a minute
um
[Music]
hey
commoners how are you doing sir
pam
i'm going to talk about in a minute
because i've got other news that came
through last night
that
puts
stargate
in a little bit of an unusual situation
and andrew one of my closest
doing a video yesterday and andrew
messaged me saying i'm gonna have to go
to bed because i'm in trouble for being
getting up at 3am so i think somebody
got in trouble from their wife to come
and watch my silly little show so thank
you so much andrew for that
to go on well with this comes down from
stargate goes on to another story that
i've heard so not only they're now
redundancies at mgm potentially
um contracts are definitely not being
renewed which is a very easy way to slim
down the workforce
the sources that i'm speaking to are
telling me that they believe
and this is only their opinion so it's
rumor it's opinion it's not official but
this is and then they're coming from the
employees at mgm but they believe this
is because the work that they will be
doing producing tv producing movies will
not be done by mgm they're shifting all
of this to amazon studios they've got
people there already that do this sort
of thing and they've got people there
now
and
basically
amazon doesn't want the people they just
want the intellectual properties so i'm
certain not all not everybody will lose
their jobs but a good chunk of people
are going to be losing their jobs at mgm
sadly which is completely against the
promises amazon were making six months
ago
i did a video a little while ago saying
to you about how the two top executives
from mgm left
um abdi the one of these executives was
the person that a lot of the mgm
employees i speak to are most angry at
because it was their name her name on
all of these memos and emails that were
coming through to amazon through through
amazon to mgm
are telling them not to worry that when
the sale went through this is back when
the ftc was still actually looking into
the sale and they wasn't 100 certain the
sale would be allowed to go through
telling all the employees don't worry
mgm is going to continue as it is you're
a great studio we love what you do we're
not going to mess with this amazon are
going to continue just to be a customer
basically and we're going to order great
television from you we're going to work
together and create amazing new movies
and projects
as soon as those two top executives
resigned
um pushed out whatever or resigned on
the principle of thing because they've
been lied to
um
amazon changed their tone slightly and
said well because of covid we're afraid
we can't do this we're going to have to
make cuts we're going to have to do this
we're going to it's going to be painful
but who knew covered is going to happen
i would argue two years ago codes had
happened but anyway they they knew code
was happening because it was happening
when the sale was going through so i
don't understand why these lies
were told
except i do understand why these lies
are told because they were told because
they wanted to keep the mgm people quiet
keep them happy
and not stir anything while the ftc was
still investigating another message
same thing
um
so
the other piece of news that i was told
yesterday which i was going to do a
video on which is again a little bit
bittersweet
um
i hate to say these promises were made
before the streaming issues have popped
up
yes and no
the streaming issues yes have popped up
but again i think that was foreseen and
what chris means here is basically over
the last six months or so um streaming
numbers new subscribers to streaming
channels have slowed
plateaued
um the competition from disney plus has
meant that there's massive growth and
taking up a lot of the pool of people
willing to pay stream of services but
also now because we have
a crisis in the cost of living people
are actually looking at maybe i
shouldn't have three four or five
streamer services maybe i should only
have one or two
um and a lot of streams seriously big
companies are actually expecting a
decline netflix has actually been seeing
a definite plateau but even a decline in
numbers which is the first time it's
ever happened in their um existence
they've always steadily increased
numbers so yes i would agree with you
that
this has these promises were made before
then but they were foreseen promises
these are things that they knew was
almost certainly going to happen um the
one person i talk to does work in the
marketing side of things and they say
they do work in legal signing contracts
things but they work in marketing they
look at trends
they've known this for at least six
months so this was going to happen so
amazon knew for at least six months that
this was going to happen but they
continued saying these lies until about
six weeks ago
so yes and no on there chris
so the other piece of news i was told
the other piece of news basically is
that and also
you should drop me a super chat every
time i say the word basically i've
noticed in videos i say it a lot and i'm
going to do a drinking game on these
days where i'll take a shot of something
every time i say basically in a video i
promise you i'll be hammered by the end
of it
um
so basically
there's news that 2001 a space odyssey
is going to be turned into a tv series
there's also talk potentially about the
forbidden planet having the same
treatment now this is news again i told
you a little while ago that there's
conversations going on no rumors that
this was happening
those rumors have been sort of like
talked about again
but the people again at mgm that i
talked to have said though it's not
going to be mgm studios that are going
to make that tv series
the conversations about how to move
forward with that are happening at
amazon studios now i know that doesn't
seem that important because
um amazon owns mgm
but the people
that were planning to make that show
work at mgm
so they thought that the show runner
everyone else would would be people
contracted with mgm
but it's amazon that are looking at it
and it's amazon studios and amazon
executives that are doing it which is
perfectly within their rights they now
own those ips
now i think that's quite exciting i i
think like i look at things like
westworld i think that's worked really
well i'm really looking forward to
resident evil and that comes out soon
again there's a big movie franchise i
think can work in a streaming tv series
and you know 10 hours over 10 episodes
gives you a lot more chance for
character development and things like
this so i think there are certain
projects like 2001 space odyssey for me
that could actually be they could
actually do something really exciting
given the budget they get nowadays
and um
tv show no one wants it but yeah what
they're going to do anyway the problem
is the 2001 space odyssey's chris always
ends up in like the top when they ever
do like um surveys and things it always
ends up in a lot of like top two or
three most popular um sci-fi shows or
sci-fi movies in history so that they're
definitely going to do this then
forbidden planet always goes up really
high in those lists as well
so
um so they're looking at doing this tv
series and i say i think it could
actually have a really good opportunity
there because it gives a lot more
character development remember 2001
space odyssey is based on a novel there
were three sequels 2010 through century
so um there's a lot of material there to
work off i think those would be like 10
episode miniseries and i think it would
look something like westworld the reason
why i think 2001 why amazon want to do
that is because they want to do
something
it's just somebody else who says they've
been given um
just literally been told they've got um
their contracts being reneged and that
they're going to be having to go on
garden leave as well that they're having
to literally get their stuff together
now
that's two people i know now that um
that i normally talk to out of um 11
that um i've been told they need to
leave immediately
um
i'm already i i feel the basically thing
now i've raised that is going to get
thrown in my face a lot
yeah
uh 100
common is that it's 100
um
so the main reason why i think they want
to make 2001 space odysseys because they
want to make something that will get
them some like
um credit they want to do something
that's going to maybe win them a couple
of awards so i think you're going to
expect to see something very artistic in
design and they'll spend a lot of money
on the music and things like this
they'll probably get quite an a-list
star to star on it because again it is
quite character-driven but it's for big
chunks of it there's only like sort of
focused on one person
um
i think that's going to be something
that is very for me i'll probably find
it quite boring but they want something
that's going to gets them some um
critical acclaim rather than you know
something that's actually entertaining
yeah same old amazon
same old amazon of course it's all about
the money
um
as possible
well again the country and it's not just
me and it's like again it's a lot of
people that aren't just
um that don't just talk to me there's a
lot they're telling me that it's people
that they work with that are getting
things but two of them have been told
they're on contract leave immediately
so
um yeah
that jack thank you for being a member
sir i really appreciate it
um
so
that's why that's why i think they're
doing 201 space odyssey how does that
come to stargate though well my concern
is
if amazon have shifted stargate into
amazon studios
or if they've shifted 2001 space odyssey
etcetera into amazon studios and they're
basically cutting mgm out
could they do the same with stargate now
this is completely based on my opinion
i've not been told anything either way
about this but it seems logical
if they do that does that mean whatever
mgm have done up till this point
will shift over to amazon with them uh
is amazon executives going to be
contacting brad wright and saying
instead of coming into mgm
um headquarters in um beverly hills
you're going to come to amazon
headquarters and speak to the amazon
executives instead
we're instead of producing this with
emgm people we're going to producing
this with amazon people
at amazon studios
again it doesn't seem to make that much
difference because amazon owns it they
can do what they want with it
but it is definitely not what was
promised
and brad wright's contracts are with mgm
not with amazon
so
and it's not as simple as just saying
well amazon amazon own mgm now because
mgm still exists as a company it's owned
by a parent company
um so legally there are some things
there
um
it seems like they're flowing they're
flying based on the war chains they're
making all the problems and bought
things make noise yep
100 jack this is why i'm making these
videos so i'm asking you guys get out
there and share these videos share this
information because people aren't
talking about this and again amazon
aren't making redundancies at the moment
so this isn't going to make the news all
they're doing at the moment is cutting
and ending contracts
they're allowed to do that and nobody
will care nobody in the mainstream media
will talk about this at all even though
they're going to slim their contract you
know they're in the workforce down and
they're cutting the heart out of mgm as
far as i'm concerned
so with stargate
if it moves over to amazon i can see
that the amazon tv people will be
involved in that
i don't know if that means brad wright
is out at this point but i would suggest
possibly
i would suggest that they will start
again and what i think i can tell you is
that from the people that were talking
to me says that they were working really
hard on stargate up until about four
weeks ago
they actually had two projects they were
working on at one point they had two
scripts they were working on
and one got scrapped about eight weeks
ago and they decided to focus on brad
wright script bradswright's script was
written three years ago and then an
update was done about a year ago and it
was that second updated script that they
were working on
and they'd gone as far as doing some
preliminary artwork and things to show
executives this isn't storyboarding and
stuff but it was stuff to the show
executives say this is this is
this is what we're envisaging
about four weeks ago early april when
they had um these meetings um between
amazon and mgm executives i'm told all
work on that stopped immediately
and so something was said in one of
those meetings that basically meant the
project that they were working on just
stopped
um what that means we don't know this
point
two weeks after that the mgm executives
the top mgm executives resigned
so i don't think it takes a rocket
scientist to say two and two equals four
on this one that something was decided
in those meetings
and i
can only go back to i think the heart is
being ripped out of this
would love to see basically put one
tenth of what he's putting into the lord
of the rings to get stargate 100
and check again what part appeals to
business vanity and maybe that'll get
going maybe
i think the only way we're going to get
something going on stargate now is if we
start yelling about it and i do think
the bring back stargate hashtag bring
back stargate um we need to start
pushing that again um i think there's a
lot of people out there doing really
good work for bring back star getting in
the 375 365 days i don't know many days
from a year 365 days of stargate project
on twitter hashtag that
um if we talk about it we yell about it
amazon do listen to things like this
but at the moment
stargate
looked like we could actually get
something announced by july
when the 25th anniversary
was released it looks like now mgm are
pushing for the game timekeepers to be
announced
and that will be the sort of big news
they're actually hoping to get
timekeepers released in a beta version
um which is a pretty cool looking game a
strategy game where you get to jump
between the time frames that we know and
love of stargate
between sg-1 and stargate atlantis the
very least um it's a role-play game so
you get to move this it's not very
action-packed but it's um it's looks
fine looks interesting they're hoping to
get that released by the anniversary so
that will be probably as much as we get
i think
um six weeks ago
mgm genuinely believed they were going
to be allowed to push forward with a few
big projects including stargate and
james bond
and then amazon completely pulled the
rug from under their feet
and that we're now
we're in no man's land again we don't
know where we're going
the companion did another reading yeah i
did so brad accessible from the brand at
least
i i think i think brad wright
for a long time has known that this
might be a risk and i think that's one
of the reasons why he shouts
and goes on about a stargate on
companion why a lot of these actors are
coming back and doing these companion ai
readings and things to try and keep the
momentum going i think that's why these
these things like james mosey's tweet
about the the second version of the
script i'm saying look it exists here's
the front copy um is the front page it
exists let's we will talk about it where
five chevrons are encoded for a new
stargate series because i don't think
brad wright is stupid he knows this
industry and he knows this industry very
very well he knows how it works
he must have had it in the back of his
mind that this was a possibility um or a
probability
and now
so i'm just trying to keep you guys
involved as well i'm sure you'll pay
attention thousands of people cancel
prime memberships and protest
millions thousands it wouldn't knows
um
we got to do something i think but the
thing is you don't even have to do that
amazon listen to social media so much
they will they will green light projects
based on social media look at all the
expanse there was a social media frenzy
the expanse got taken from um from
netflix and
amazon agreed to take it on
if you're a lover of the expanse i would
say the same thing because i say i did a
video a couple of days ago guys talking
about how
budgets and this stream service problem
has hit a lot of other projects
including
things like babylon 5 um with the warner
brothers and
the expanse they were thinking seriously
about doing a spin-off of that so i'm
not sure you know and now it's been just
put on hold not cancelled it's like the
same with stargate it's not dead
but
it's going to take longer because of
this problem and it comes down to money
at the end of the day
amazon i believe had no intention of
keeping mgm in its current form they
were always going to get it
and just absorb it as i mean actually
one of the um amazon executives that's
what he called he said that we're going
to absorb mgm into amazon prime and
amazon studios
all they wanted was the ip all i wanted
was the rights to all these classic
movies and tv shows that mgm owns things
like rocky creed
um robocop i think and which is looking
like also might be looking for another
tv series as well or a movie
um things like 2001 space odyssey things
like forbidden planet things like
stargate and james bond that's all they
were interested in they wanted those
rights
and now they've gone
and mgm will basically only be mgm in
name there will actually be no substance
there'll be no buildings there'll be no
p it'll just be in name
um it'll be
slapped on like a badge and a car
you know and that'll be it so we'll get
to see the line at the start maybe and
then it'll be in association with amazon
pictures but really it's just amazon
that's all it is
all right guys so
that's the news
it sucks
it really sucks i'm just so sorry for
again the people that talk to me they do
it at risk
um apparently there was an email that
went round mgm um about three months ago
saying don't talk to
um websites like sidetrack i it wasn't
just me there was a list of about 10 or
12 youtube channels that there was um
you know
told that people were told not to talk
to and but i was quite pleased with mine
so my little hobby of a channel got
named in that list um
it's
i really do i have to i have to say i
have to put my hands up to you guys to
say so thank you and i know you're going
through so much stress at the moment and
the messages i get are almost constant
now
have been for the last hour and a half
because when it's only caught caught
past 10 in an a this is literally
happening now as i'm talking to you
um
even the people that aren't you know
being put at risk on having redundancies
that's what they're fearing that's what
they think is next
um
i just i just feel sorry
it's a sad ending for what a legendary
company dale i 100 agree with you this
is one of the big five studios
you know it's mgm fox paramount
universal
and disney they were the top five and
amazon have come in and gutted this
company i mean a company that were lucky
to exist i mean they nearly went out a
little while ago but
it's just sad
dave good evening i always say
i think i think i agree with you see
chris says it there then we this is what
everybody said was going to happen
but then amazon lied they lined for six
months to a year
another one
saying his job safe bought
two people at work on his floor have
just been escorted out by security
two people on one floor
see that how does that make everybody
else feel when they see things like that
and amazon mgm will say well we're not
making anybody redundant we're just
relieving contracts it's just we're just
ending contracts short-term contracts so
you know they're not doing anything
wrong
maybe not and this is escorting them out
by security i know that sounds really
dramatic but apparently that happens all
the time anybody that goes out and
gardening because people they just don't
want people to you know like take the
take the state blue with them and things
which i can understand good evening wiki
how are you
um
trouble is amazon do stuff well but i've
never thought tv's produced by amazon
are great i can't put my finger on it
but they missed the mark for me
the other thing is amazon don't tend to
do a lot of projects themselves they
always tend to be in association with
one of the big studios they work a lot
with colombia
and companies like that
um so now i think those that's how it
will continue
they'll continue to make those projects
but now they can make the projects they
now have these new rights so they can
make creed and they can make things that
to be fair though mgm has been doing
exactly the same thing they don't make a
lot of material on their own and they
haven't been for a long time they tend
to make projects in association with a
company that actually owns studios
that's one thing mgm don't actually own
studio
their studio that used to be in
carson city i think in california they
sold it to sony years ago they don't
actually own a studio themselves so
amazon really just transferring what mgm
have already been doing into their own
um
into their own offices
it's just that there's a lot of people
at film gym at the moment that
are very talented people that mgm keep
going on and on about we want these
talented people these talented
storytellers
and they're just going to be
doing what to them
you know um are they going to keep the
building the mgm building
if it does it will have mgm on the side
of it but in name only we don't know
and that's what i feel sorry about i
feel sorry for these people that
have
you know that have this uncertainty at
the moment
um
and that's who i feel sorry for it's
it's just sad
anyway
it's rubbish news i apologize i have to
be again
to to share this uncertainty at the
moment and i mean at the end of the day
we want a tv show to come back but it's
actually these people's jobs and these
people's livelihoods i'm just glad that
i said that the one person i speak to
he's basically said he's gonna walk
straight out and walk straight into
another job so great um he's a very
talented person i've seen a lot of his
work before and it's just fantastic so
that's that's great news other people
that might not be so lucky
amazon charges for their seriously on
top they charge for their shows yeah
they do uh i don't know how amazing get
away with it they have
they have the the the prime and then
they have they'll be super channels like
mgm in the uk mgm has a super channel
you have to pay another five pound
[ __ ]
amazon prime is already more expensive
than um disney and look at everything's
on disney no one don't get me wrong i'm
not a big fan of disney as a corporation
as a business but disney plus is a
channel it's fantastic as soon as they
took on all the fox stuff as well
and absorb all that and it's all and one
price and one reasonable price i know
they're keeping it they're basically
running on a loss to trying to keep up
with and try to overtake netflix and
they're gonna they'll succeed
um but it's an absolutely brilliant
platform amazon compared it's rubbish
and it's hard to navigate you want you
then find something you want to watch
and realize it's not on primes you have
to pay for it um or it's um or it's also
on these locked up in these sub channels
i hate amazon prime i don't know why
bother keeping it really
um amazon can do what they want but they
do what they want at the risk of
alienate the consumers 100 percent
yeah i had to sell mgm and paramount
even though i don't get access to
everything
it's just a swiss
and it's it's these people again screwed
over though that's that that's the thing
i can't
john campbell so did anyone actually
believe that amazon were going to keep
the promises i never expected just to
say the merger i knew mgm was a goner
yeah i think i agree with you john to be
honest but i didn't want to be cynical
and
when they were being told these things
people believed it i think because they
wanted to believe it particularly the
people i speak do they want to do
because it's their jobs so they were
hoping that yeah amazon was going to
come in and just be
um
a
an owner yes but a
consumer you know a customer they were
going to buy products off mgm and put it
on amazon prime
they were going to still be allowed
because it's what they were being told
that you're a great storyteller you're
one of the great storytellers in the
world
carry on what you're doing
um and yeah we were foolish for
believing it
just had an email subs up 15.99 carl
yeah i've seen that as well i get my
netflix free through sky
look at that get sky it's quite good
um if you get sky in the uk and then you
also get sky movies which is quite
expensive but there's a big deal at the
moment we're getting quite cheap and
you'll be getting paramount plus for
free
um on the 22nd spot sky movies so
paramount plus in the uk will be
available on sky from the 22nd
um so apparently should be quite good if
you're a trekkie at all
um
you know as soon as services become
impacting my life spidey senses start to
go off and i'm going to question whether
i need it in my life
and that's what a lot of people are
doing and that's why a lot of projects
we
you know are looking at is going to be
disappearing
how do you still have an mgm subchannel
as disney plus asking more to watch star
wars or marvel yeah
and and that's what i mean disney get
away with disney do it and
they do it for free they do it within
think but mgm in the uk
is a sub channel it costs 5.99 more or
4.99 more
and it's rubbish
stargate isn't even on it
which is absolutely rubbish um stargate
for me is on starting from the sky
so
what if that will work its way out to no
tv let's hope so paul for you guys uh
paul's obviously in the uk
so yeah so
i'm just disappointed and i'm but i'm
sad for the people again that i'm i
don't want to read any more of my
messages to be honest i've just had
another one come through
one person saying that they're just
worried that they're
oh i just seen somebody crying in the
reception
they've literally just walked the one
person i speak to i can't really tell
you what they do because it'll identify
them but and they know people that are
coming going from the building um yeah
he's just said he's just that was it's
sad he's just a literate walk past
somebody crying in the building
it's just sad
um
but yeah this is this is where we're at
at the moment
again guys if you are new to the channel
please like subscribe hit the bell
notification and please share the
channel wherever you see
um if you if you like what i do and you
want to see me do more of it um
i need your money i'm afraid i'm sorry
but i just do
and the wi-fi let me do else so please
consider joining the channel becoming a
member
obviously any super chats things like
that they really help me out i don't
want to read i just vibrated again don't
want to read it
um
and yeah please like get out there and
tell the story because if people don't
know then amazon are just gonna well
amazon gonna do what they want anyway
they will do what they want anyway and
if public opinion starts turning against
them all they will do is they will
announce some new big tv show or
something and we'll all we won't worry
about
i will forget very quickly
um
just buy a flowers work for me today
when you got up at three o'clock in the
morning already did andrew i love that i
told my wife i woke my wife up
one of my subscribers woke up at 3
o'clock in the morning to go watch my tv
show how cool is that
my silly little tv show but anyway
so guys
jack do you ever talk about
what you do aside from this
um i would i i guys if you want to know
anything about me please i will more
than happily ask questions about that um
i can't really because i work in um
adult social care so i can't say a great
deal thank you so much paul likes today
things like this helps keep the channel
going really really
thank you
my name is actually jamie
um walter so my name is actually jamie
and if you go on facebook and join the
facebook group i'm jamie riverson so you
can see me on there i'm the only one
that ever adds anything to the channel
so i'm really easy to find and you can
also dm me if you want to instant
message me you can catch me through
there um
just be warned um one person tried to
then contact my wife through there and
they got very quickly blocked from the
channel so don't do that not that you
ever would because you're not creepy
um
up all night andrew again
yeah
so yes my name is actually uh jamie
um
but yes i work in also i actually have a
psychology background so my background
is working in mental health but now i
work in um adult social care so i work
with children uh sorry adults with
learning disabilities so that's my main
job i'm trying to get out four days a
week
so that i can concentrate at least one
day a week for everybody here in the uk
and i can do these this channel at least
solidly one day a week it's not just as
it's make better better content but also
i guess to fight you quicker
um
i can't literally live off
youtube pennies for adverts you know it
just doesn't work
um so i do need i i would
if i want to go on to
you know that that next level
um we need to do that but i i'm not here
to beg for money it's just that if you
like what i produce
if you can hit that like button you can
hit that share button and you can hit
that little like button that's on the
videos and you can contribute to the
channel and it helps out
time for lunch i'm gonna go and make
myself some lovely tea
um
paul works with a local photographer
millions wish it was mine yeah
sent to the news agencies thank you very
much deanna
why not
it's just sad and let's hope somebody
picks it up and actually runs with it uh
i subscribe but may want to push that a
bit
please subscribe guys
i'm gonna go and i'm gonna make myself
some tea now
i'm a bit depressed i might crack open a
beer so guys
thank you so much for watching um again
like subscribe do all that business like
blah blah i will see you all really
really soon thanks for watching
good night chaps
oh i've gotta do the thing i've gotta do
the uh
i always forget this
a subscriber and a main subscriber made
me an intro and i keep forgetting to use
it so here we go
[Music]
you